HELLO EVERYBODY!!!!!!!!!
AYYYY STOP.
Wha-- whott-- why?
I just don't get it
I always catch you fuckers watching this sick shit
THIS IS SICKENING.
THE DISASTER ARTIST
WOOW
PEWDIEPIE, DID YOU HEAR ABOUT THE NEW MOVIE THEY'RE MAKING? THE DISASTER ARTIST?
No, no. I've never heard of it!!!!!!!!!!
Please tell me more!!!!!
SOMEONE NEEDS TO TELL YOU THAT THEY ARE MAKING A MOVIE ABOUT TOMY WISEAU AND THE ROOM, IT'S CALLED "THE DISASTER ARTIST"
OH!! WOW!!
THAT'S INCREDIBLE!!
HOW DID I NOT KNOW THIS??
You need to see the trailer for "The Disaster Artist", it's about Tommy Wiseau. But if you've already seen it, then ignore this.
Oh..ahahahah
Stop making fucking stupid videos and do a review on the Disaster arti-
Shut the f.. up! Okay, fine. I'll make a review.
That's right, I'm a movie critic now.
The Disaster Artist is a movie I never thought would exist.
Similar to the other movie review I made: BLAME.
A movie I never thought would exist either!
This is my niche! I have finally found it!
I review movies that I never thought would exist.
The Disaster Artist is a movie about a movie about a book about a movie about a book ... about -
Now, If you have seen The Room, you know exactly what I am talking about
The Disaster Artist is based on the movie The Room
I made a movie (review) about The Room
I really recommend checking it out
And I explain why I love The Room so much
It's a movie that is HILARIOUSLY BAD
and
unlike a lot of bad movies
I've talked about a lot of bad movies before on my channel
This is like when Luke Skywalker
Took off the mask of Darth Vader
Why did he need that anyway by the way -ok great- What is that thing?
The Room is [the] kind of bad movie I can re-watch
Infinite amount of times
I never get sick of it
I love showing it to people.
I love sharing information about the movie
because the more you know about The Room, the more intrigued you get by it.
So when the book came out,
from one of the guys that was in The Room
explaining how The Room was made,
called The Disaster Artist by Greg Sestero
Reading that, I just got a new-found love for the film.
It's actually a very, very interesting story, about
unlikely friendship, and
Two people, finding success in failure.
It's a very touching story,
which you wouldn't expect.
Tommy and Greg are actually very close friends.
Which, when you watch The Room, you would never have guessed.
I mean, they're complete opposites.
You have Tommy, who is really old.
Uh, sorry Tommy, if you're listening
He's clearly not American, but he wants to be.
But he's also very rich
for reasons we never find out.
And then you have Greg, who is young, American,
and doesn't have any money. But
what draws these two characters together, or people together
because this is a true story -
is them wanting to make it in Hollywood.
Wanting to become actors.
And the movie shows that.
It starts off with Greg seeing Tommy at a
drama class, and
Greg is just so intrigued by Tommy.
How he is so fearless in his acting
He's not very good, but he's so
...there's something that draws him in about him.
They become friends, and
despite their differences, they decide to move to LA together.
And try and make it in Hollywood.
And the book and the movie pretty much pens out the same way here.
I read the book about two years ago, so
my memory is a little fuzzy on the whole thing.
Tommy doesn't find any success in LA, he's
He's not a good actor. Greg finds
some success, but nothing really too overwhelming.
and I think they are both in the time where they just wanna give up
on their dream that they had together. But then they,
Tommy comes up with the idea:
I'm just gonna make my own movie, and you're gonna be in it.
And so, The Room was born.
And here's where the book and the movie really sets apart
as far as I remember:
in the movie it's very Hollywood.
where, "Oh, we're gonna make a movie and it's gonna be great!"
"Everyone's gonna be super happy!"
"Yes of course I wanna be a part of it!"
When in reality, described in the book, Greg didn't wanna be a part of the movie at all.
He actually just accepted to be part as a line producer
of the film, so
he wasn't even gonna act in the movie.
But he would be a stand-in for the actor
for his role
as Mark
Basically, he would just stand in the frame of the camera, so
the camera knows where he will be.
But Tommy wanted Greg to be in the movie.
The movie is about them, after all. It's
a reflection of their friendship.
Like I said, you would never have guessed it, but
it is the truth.
So, Tommy basically would just slowly start replacing in Greg more and more
and , to the point where he would just take over
and start acting in the film. Without even telling the original actor. Which is
Which is hilarious and horrible at the same time.
And there's a lot of bad stuff like that, that isn't in the film.
There's a lot of stuff that maybe you don't wanna really tell...
that's left out
How they constantly changed crew while making the film.
Arguing with actors during the film,
refusing to pay people during the film.
These are the sorts of things that were left out of the movie.
I understand why they did, because it would've been too long,
too convoluted,
and too complicated.
But I think they did a good job at tying it all together
they tell the story about their friendship
and the making of the movie. And I think
that was the main point.
I do think there was some miscasting in the film, it seemed like
they were all just friends that wanted to make this movie
in my opinion. Which I understand,
it's like "Oh you're making a movie about The Room? I love The Room! You have to put me in it, James!"
But other than that, it was...I couldn't have asked for more.
I thought it was extremely entertaining.
I was laughing througout the whole thing.
There was a lot of inside jokes.
Which not as many people were laughing at.
But at the same time, I realized while watching it
You don't even have to have seen The Room to enjoy The Disaster Artist.
I think that's a really, a feat of its own.
James Franco renders Tommy Wiseau in such a hilarious, relatable and endearing way
you can tell that James was really invested in Tommy's character.
I watched an interview with Seth Rogen
where he explains it, which I thought was really nice.
It was incredibly personal to him, in a weird way
and he felt this weird kinship with Tommy Wiseau
who's the guy in the movie
so we really wanted to just support him.
Someone makes a piece of art,
hoping it's received one way,
it is actually received for the exact opposite reasons
that you hoped it would
but the result is actually the same.
You become famous, people like you.
You have movie stars making movies about you.
You make money.
You get, uh, you're in profit -
Yeah, you're getting paid.
And Franco has someone who has done a lot of weird art shit
throughout his life.
Constantly being misunderstood,
misinterpreted
people thinking that the shit he thought was great was stupid
and vice versa.
It was incredibly personal to him.
In a weird way. And he felt this weird kinship with Tommy Wiseau, who's
who's the guy in the movie.
You can truly tell that James was deeply invested in Tommy's character.
Watching the teaser trailer for this film, I
got kind of annoyed, because they had already changed so much, they
skipped bits that were hilarious
so I was really worried about this film.
I did not hit her, it's not true.
It's bullshit.
I did not hit her, I did not.
Oh, hi, Mark.
Take 67.
Action.
I hit her!
No!
Do you wanna change the line?
You're doing great, man.
I did not hit her, it's not true, it's bullshit, I did not hit her, I did not.
Oh, hi Mark.
In this scene, at the end, Tommy would never look up, he would
always just forget what he was doing
and forget that he actually needs to look at the person
if he sees someone. Oh, hi Mark.
So apparently, what they did was
everyone would just wave at Tommy
when he was finishing the scene
so that he would look up.
And then he would just look up and say "Oh, hi, Mark."
And that's how they finally got the shot.
He'd also hit his head multiple times
while going out of that little box.
So, it's almost like the movie skipped out on a lot of hilarious stuff
in my opinion.
And I remember reading about this
in the book and it was just so funny
to re-live that horrible, horrible scene.
And knowing what went down
for it to happen.
I think the main difference between the movie and the book is that
the book ends right before the premiere. The movie starts.
But the movie ends
a bit after, with a nice happy ending.
I'm not sure if the ending was actually that happy.
I think anyone that was involved in the project of The Room
probably went through a really rough time.
I think it affected a lot of peoples' lives really negatively
watching interviews from a lot of the actors involved
with their careers and their confidence being destroyed
for everyone. Tommy, for Greg, for all the other actors as well
and the people making the movie not being credited properly.
And I don't think the ending of the book was a happy ending.
But I think, now
that the movie is out
and you have people loving The Room
you have people so dedicated to it.
People like me who just find so much joy in it.
It's been re-made by Hollywood superstars into a film. And it's a great story.
It's an amazing story, and I really hope, so, even
though they completely changed the ending
it makes sense now.
I think, and I really hope, that everyone involved in The Room
with this film coming out, The Disaster Artist, find
a closure, insane story of making The Room.
I think, I really hope it ends in a positive way for everyone involved
And it seems like it. It seems like Tommy has found a lot of joy
in all this attention, and
Greg as well, and
it's a life-changing thing to be a part of
and it was nice seeing it sort of being wrapped up.
Maybe I'm reading into it a bit too much, I don't know.
You can still really very much enjoy the book,
it goes way and beyond on details.
and it's hilarious.
It's good details, that I actually really recommend.
There's also an audiobook version of the book.
Which I also really recommend, because Greg reads out all the lines.
And he does Tommy Wiseau's voice so great
And it really shows that he's actually not a bad actor.
The movie doesn't replace the book and the book doesn't replace the movie.
I think you can enjoy them both individually.
It's not like it spoils anything is what I'm saying.
I'm gonna give the movie an 8.5
it was hilarious, I would love to see it again.
Some changes that I kinda disagreed with, but over all, very satisfying, I really enjoyed it.
An 8.6 I'm gonna give it.
Go watch it! Let me know what you think.
And this has been Movie Review with Pewdiepie.
Leave a like, and Squad Fam out.
You know what they say,
HI DOGGY.